[Music]
and not a good luck news being submitted
by California Redwoods beautiful trees
yep
a viral video shows ufc's Conor McGregor
punching an elderly man in a bar when
did I get hit in a bar so he really
punched an elderly guy yeah [ __ ] this
guy's problem
[ __ ] the weapons he was riding that
perfect line of controversy while still
being like a warrior
those guys get [ __ ] with more than
anybody because because they're like
these big UFC guys like people hey but
it's but it's an Irish bar isn't that a
part of it like you drink and you fight
and you drink and you fight let me tell
you the story so he's in Dublin he shows
up to a pub and he starts telling the
bartender like hey give me some shot
glasses and so he was proper for his
poker number 12 whiskey and so he starts
pouring these shots and so he gives a
shot glass to this elderly man and he
ends up saying like he ends up pushing
the glass like now I'm good like he just
wanted to drink his beer and then the
elderly man wouldn't drink his alcohol
yeah he didn't want whiskey so then
can't like McGregor ends up getting the
shot glass again and putting it for the
guy in the guy oh yeah so he was really
aggressive about wanting this man to
drink his whiskey that's a no-no Conor
McGregor when he didn't
that's when McGregor ended up punching
him I don't believe that [ __ ] show you
the video oh there's a video yeah it is
all right this way oh you got to see it
all right here we go there he has his
back towards us yes I got green thermal
shirt off mrs. corner and no he's
wearing a really tight shirt oh yeah oh
that's the victim he's seeing some
pictum Connor victim saying something
dude holy [ __ ] damn my leg up pose like
a snake he is a lethal weapon though Wow
oh come on yeah well he did not come out
so he didn't do a good job did he throw
the glass at his face no oh my god these
I didn't see both other guys reacted
fast though right
[ __ ] what a piece of [ __ ] so men loved
him do we know what the old man said was
like the others like no I feels like
your whiskey sucks I don't think it
mattered but what if it said I [ __ ]
your wife I don't think it matters did
it really happen no I expect more out of
him because I wanted to see the guy get
dropped and he's as a real fighter like
that sucks that's actually what a lot of
people are saying they're like he just
tapped them I mean compared to what may
be the old fell off his stool maybe the
old man was like is this dry-aged see I
would support it if he punched oh yeah
is this organic yeah I would not want to
get hit by that guy meaning I would have
dropped even a jab like that no he took
it like a chewy Irish man though you
went like flies like so what he kept
Riggins out that this man oh my god he's
dead no no okay good boy him when he was
a kid no this actually happened back in
April but this recently surfaced his
molars teased his molars and all his
front teeth you all spun around what did
they say so they're saying that this man
he didn't even feel it like in the
moment cuz he was already so drunk so he
didn't feel that Oh
and then afterward like you know dude
yeah the next day he ended up staying at
home for like weeks oh yeah I'm saying
like he was just like - a found out he
was a millionaire he was like oh the
pain
so what ended up happening immediately
after they took McGregor away like his
people this man got into a taxi and the
McGregor jumped out of our pool and went
into the taxi to pick him up no so they
ended up having a discussion which we
don't know what they were saying but
apparently it seems a million dollars if
you shut the [ __ ] up yeah like McGregor
was pretty much trying to apologize but
we don't know what happened and so this
man now says that he's not about like
trying to get Fame we're trying to get
money at all he just wants justice which
I don't know what that means oh oh that
means he's gonna have to pay that's all
I mean it's easy-peasy wants money
that's exactly get thrown in jail for
that Kenny I don't know I don't know
about Ireland mo Ireland they might have
different rules because they're like we
all fight remember last time to those
people a culture he did get charged with
assault when he threw the steel of Dali
through but that's not island you know
America I know in Ireland that could be
a handshake to the face
you know like to the face so the cat
sitting there you gets drunk enough
where he Conor McGregor can punch him he
doesn't even feel - the next day if I'm
the next fighter I'm about to fight
Conor McGregor I'm [ __ ] pounding
shots
yeah like then you go in there you're
invincible this is opposite brand who
the competitor - parole that's pretty
much mr. mop i watch it yeah yeah watch
it but I'm not familiar with all the
names but you know I I check it out it's
um you know it's wild do you get the
inside scoop when Joe Rogan comes and
tells you everything yeah yeah no it's
uh it's it's one of those things like
it's kind of like you know my generation
had boxing right
and my generations boxers are older now
yeah and they're probably [ __ ] up you
know like up here you know concussions
or you know you ever see boxers or yeah
NFL players yeah I'm I'm I'm very
curious to see what its gonna be like in
20 30 years with the UFC I mean you see
how [ __ ] up there and they always say
like oh it's not as bad as boxing I
don't buy that
because their [ __ ] ears are like
cauliflowers and they're getting smashed
yeah I mean you know it started off with
wasn't it didn't start off like backyard
wrestling like that's where this whole
thing and it just shows you peep
want to see people beat the [ __ ] out of
each other yeah I mean people love it
the most primal thing ever yeah it's
like people love it and they love it so
much now women are doing it which is
[ __ ] insane you know watch some of
these fights you like [ __ ] she could
kill me yeah I don't want to get in the
green with that chick she's gonna smash
me yeah you know what I think would be
funny and I thought about this I think
it'd be funny if there was a female UFC
fighter fighting just a normal guy like
him
how hilarious wait who oh really
I thought Carlos bars a shot a normal
guy yeah he got [ __ ] oh really fun a
real UFC yeah we didn't go 100% we spar
but just from the sparring or she killed
she killed me yeah yeah yeah in like 30
seconds but I think if you get maybe get
a match you know someone like a really
gnarly big dude I was just kind of being
kidding with you but I'm just saying
like oh I see why no but like a big deal
like a football player do to someone
that you think you guys aren't too
gnarly yeah I'm just saying I think that
would be cool you know Amy right like
having a chick beat the [ __ ] up but do
you always laugh at that am i bad person
i when I when I see videos of dudes
getting wailed on by their chick I just
I love that I can't handle it I love it
it wouldn't lose-lose situation for the
guy in there though because if he wins
he's a woman beater it loses he lost to
a girl yeah if you really [ __ ] punch
you know she's got a like look in the
camera or sign something saying no I'm
open season yeah like you know I'm not
gonna get I'm not gonna sue you or come
after you if you punch me in the face
she's gotta like agree to it yeah even
if I hear it though I still see it
happen I'm like that kind of piece of
[ __ ] I lost respect for that dude don't
know [ __ ] that guy but I would love to
see a chick beat the [ __ ] out of a guy
who be hilarious yeah have you so you've
never witnessed that cuz I feel like
your life sitting this witness way I
don't know just witnessed a girl beat
somebody I don't know I feel like I feel
like crazy [ __ ] goes out of control
getting a picture like a lady comic
beating down Bobby Lee he did something
and then she [ __ ] started whaling on
him or something hmm or something in the
back room you know something happened
yeah so what's happened to Colin
MacGregor no none of the tape is out now
that this has happened the reaction
there was this one pub owner in Florida
that was filming
all of his bartender staff grabbing a
bottle of opera and flushing it down the
toilet in front of his his uh poster
framed poster exactly what they left the
framed poster up so that's important no
he'd they put the poster like right
where the toilet is
oh I'm in my quarter and then flush it
down without his permission so he just
lose an alcohol money no shame [ __ ]
sucks
I see yeah they're saying that now
problem number 12 is banned from that
pub like they need him because they're
just like even fans I have supported him
through all of these controversies
they're just saying like dude this was
so uncalled for and I you're just a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah there's no I can afford to be if
anyone can fight your team it was like
fifty mil or something thirteen with
Mayweather
yeah that's thirty Jesus verse thirty
god no I think it was a hundred oh my
god 100 million from the Mayweather
fight yeah you could punch somebody in
the face every day
mm like with that kind of bag yeah the
lifestyle the lifestyle you could burn
it all to now she's depending on the
lifestyle if he's punch me yeah cuz if I
make that kind of money like I'm just
disappearing from entertainment
completely and just like oh no like I
don't know I just want to say you know
at least you can really love
entertainment Wow yeah I just want to
run away you know I'm doing this all for
the money you're so [ __ ] weird though
you'd be like in the middle of a forest
[ __ ] butt ass naked doing some weird
dance people are filming you like
looking like weird my last watch yeah
and then you're famous again so uh I
don't want to be always arch-nemesis
yeah the Honorable warrior he
okay are there settles kabhi kabhi be
look it is this guy looks like he has a
mouth you know this is like really
really bad thing you know like even it's
all the guy like this guy on video even
this guy finds your face same time hey
you can't punch this guy's face yeah can
this is like impossible you know this is
like we have to respect all people I
don't understand this I think like these
people I have to go jail
Wow free ones calling me go to jail yeah
he's pretty much calling out for Dublin
authorities to be like hey man check
check your dude yeah he's just over
there though they might just give him
like all kinds of they might line up 10
old guys for him to president that's
just how we do it here in Arlen that's
like patio he do whatever the [ __ ] he
wants
yeah he could just show the shoot
somebody in broad daylight in there like
yeah I want to be that immortal see
that's you got to do something for your
country to the point where they love you
and nothing can happen toy dog that's
got to happen